hello everyone and welcome back to round
the 19 of the 1970 Palma de Majorca
inter-zonal tournament and as you might
have gotten the impression this is a
very long tournament 24 players battling
it out everyone against everyone
so 23 games will be played and you know
for those of you who are perhaps
spending the Saturday night at home you
are in for quite a treat as here in
round 19 Bobby Fischer faces none other
than Mark Temenos now I don't think
marked a man who needs any introduction
we've already had a lot of videos about
him and if you know you have studied
some chess history or you know it even
if you've studied just a little you know
one book there there is no way that you
have not heard of marked atamanov one of
the strongest so via the grandmasters at
that time probably a member of the top
10 elite okay maybe not the top 10 but
definitely top 20 elite of the world
elite chess grandmasters and this is
what Bobby came here to do he came to
windy inter-zonal to win the candidates
to win the World Chess Championship and
to do that he has to beat the Russians
or the Soviets so that being said we do
have a nice photo challenge I prepared
for this game so there you have it who
are the two gentlemen in this photo
shouldn't be a difficult one but next
one will be difficult so here here's an
easy one so there we have it and we
don't have a photo of this matchup
Fisher versus the amount of from the
1970 palma de mallorca inter-zonal but
of course we do have one from their 1971
candidates match in Vancouver it's
actually an excellent photo so you know
let's let's just enjoy it and prepare
for this game so there we have it
Fischer has the white pieces and he
opens with E 4 we have c5 tamaño goes
for the Sicilian Knight to f3 and the
knight to c6 d4 C capture some d4 Knight
captures on d4 and here at the amount of
plays c6 which is the diamond of
variation of the Sicilian
nice to be 5 we have D 6 and here C 4 is
played it's a it's pretty much a common
thing in the Sicilian if
Blackstone's with the development of
this night and yuri for point is not
attacked if you can you know if you have
the opportunity you know feel free to
pull the c4 point before developing your
knight on c3 even if it's even if it's
like the beginning of the game efore c5
Knight f3 and if black for some example
goes for this a6 move the the O'Kelly
variation of the Sicilian you can even
go see for here prevent the expansion
here with the b5 also you will get a
very nice grip on the d5 square but ok
here after d6 the Fisher goes for c4 now
really controlling that d5 square a
six-night goes back to C 3 we have
Knight to f6 and Bishop to e2 Bishop to
e7 vitamin of Bobby castles we have
castles and now as there is already a
knight on c3 and you do have to develop
your be one night knife to a3 we have b6
Bishop to e3 and the now comes Bishop to
d7 rope the c1 Queen to be 8 now adding
further protection to the b6 pawn and
also now the d6 pawn is attacked twice
as here you can see the Fischer has a
knight on a three knight on c3 the pawn
and Bishop here are all very nicely
guarding the be 5 square so there it's
not very likely that black will be able
to put b5 anytime soon and also the
Knights the Queen C pawn upon are all
guarding the d5 square so d5 will also
not be a breakthrough for for black
anytime soon
f3 we have rook to e7 and the now comes
nice to see to rock to d8 Queen to e1
and now Bishop to e8 now the the rock
from the 8 is guarding the d6 pawn and
perhaps black will be able to put d5 at
some point Queen to f2 attacking the b6
pawn rook to b7 defending the pawn also
now preparing to port b5 so Fisher stops
at a four now da poor as well
keeps an eye on the b v square we have a
5 and the now comes Knight to d4 you
don't want this night ever to come to b5
there it will simply be too much of a
too much of a menace
so Knight captures on d4 we have Bishop
captures on d4
now Knight to d7 you generally don't
want to play something like e five ever
in a position like this then you will
never be able to put d5 and white will
now simply have too many options and in
the hands of a strong Grandmaster this
is most likely a enough to even win the
position so after Bishop to d4 Knight to
d7 preparing to remain over denied
either to c5 or a five queen to g3
now Fischer is threatening Queen
captures and g7 checkmate rush up to f6
and now Bishop captures Knight captures
and rook F to D 1 we have E 5 there's
really not a lot of moves you can do
here for black Fischer is still keeping
an eye on the b v square and the d5
square so no breakthroughs or possible
it's really very unlikely that you can
do a useful move with any of the rooks
or with the Queen the bishop doesn't
really have anywhere to go
so you don't have to change the you know
the structure of the pawns to create
something so e5 we have Queen to h4 by
Fischer h6 and now comes Rock to d2 roof
to d2 is a very nice move by Fischer as
you can see the bishop from e8 is
attacking the a 4-point Fischer would
perhaps enjoy playing a move like Knight
to d5 in the future or something but you
can't do it as you're a four ponies
attack so look to d2 preparing a Bishop
to d1 to protect the a4 pawn and then
the knight will be able to move but even
that moves like Knight to d7 to c5 are
coming and then there will be a double
attack against da for pawn and Fisher
wants to be ready so nice to d7
we have Bishop to d2 d1 now heading for
further protection to the a4 pawn
Knights the c5 Fischer is now prepared
for this and we have f4 he captures on
f4 Queen captures on f4 and now night
this night to e6 attacking Fischer's
Queen Queen to g3 we have Queen to c7
attacking the c4 pawn and now of course
nice to d5 attacking the Queen and now
the rock from c1 is also guarding the c4
pawn queen to c5 this comes with check
King to h1 and now comes Bishop to c6
we have rook to c3
and night the g5 attacking the e4 pawn
bishop to see to defending and now comes
Bishop captures on d5 and here you can
capture with either pawns or you can
capture with the rook if you capture
with the C pawn then Queen before
attacks the B to pawn also you can't
move the c3 rook as your DD to rope is
hanging so you don't want to allow black
so much activity with the Queen if you
capture with the other pawn rook pawn
captures then rook e8 comes and the
black now controls the entire efile
after you do go rogue d1 then this rogue
comes to e7 and again too much activity
for black so Fisher had something else
in mind
rook captures on d5 attacking the Queen
Queen to c7 and now comes he v Fischer
managed to get rid of his weak key for
pawn he will trade it and also now this
bishop becomes a very nice piece the
captures Queen captures offering a trade
of Queens rook D to b8 now if the
Queen's are traded on c7 or the rook
from b8 is already guarding the b6 pawn
bishop to f5 and now comes the Queen
captures on e5 rook captures on e5 and
now G sex attacking Fischer's bishop so
instead of moving the bishop right away
first h4 we have Knight back to h7
Bishop to g4 now improving the position
Knight back to f6 and Bishop to f3 now
the bishop will be controlling the night
from f3 beautifully and it comes with
tempo is the broken b7 is under attack
rook to d7 and here comes Rock to b5
here a very nice position for for
Fischer c5 is definitely a threat you
will not be able to capture as the
rockin b8 is hanging and here the best
thing you can do is move the rook back
move the rook back and now the game
continues now c5 will not be such a big
big thing the rooks are defending each
other you will be able to capture here
and after captures here it will be a
nice position you can simply improve the
position of your King either rooks will
be traded or if you capture the pawn
here then tomorrow we'll be able to able
to capture the pawn on on b2 but instead
after going back atamanov played rock to
d4 first he said ok your pawns are too
too vulnerable here if you pulled upon
now okay me I will not be able to
capture as my rook is undefended but I
will capture here this will come with
check I will be able to capture on a for
so surely this must be good but you know
as it often is in chess you know things
happen so Fisher did push c5 yell out
the amount of the capture on h4 rook
captures on h4 with check this is you
have to react to this King g1 only move
and now rook B for forcing a trade here
but Fisher says no problem rook captures
pawn captures rook goes to C for
attacking the pawn pawn captures on c5
and here comes the rook captures on c5
so pretty much a forced variation where
Fischer lost a point so the amount of is
here is up a pawn in this position but
it doesn't matter if you look at the
position now Fischer has a bishop on f3
against a knight on f6 the bishop is
much stronger than the night you know
not only does it counter the movements
of the night but also it guards the
queening square da it's square and
Fischer has a pest a pawn
so Fischer is very very close to
queening the spawn and black will have
very hard time stopping it King to g7
was played now comes a five Fischer
pushes his passed pawn it's a passport
not a fast pawn rook to e8 tamaño would
very much enjoy playing rook e1 check
and rook to a-1 bring it bring his rook
behind officials passed pawn Fischer
doesn't allow it
rook the c1 and now comes rook to e5
attacking Fisher Fisher spawn and now if
you push it then comes Rock a5 again you
will put a rogue behind a fast pawn and
although you can defend it you will no
longer be able to push it as a 7 is a
dark square
so after rookie 5 rook to a 1 now
Fischer puts his rook behind the passed
pawn rook to e7 you do have to block the
pawn from a dark square King to f2 and
night the e8 now we have a 6
rook to a7 you have to block the pond
from from a dark square and now King III
now Fischer is preparing to bring his
King over here if he brings his King
over to b6 the game is over 97 we have
Bishop to b7 the
the pond on a six-night goes back and
now a very nice move by fit by Fisher
rook to a5 not allowing this night to
come to c5 to harass the bishop and the
pawn king to f6 we have King to d3 king
to e7 king to c4 and king to d6 and here
you can choose whether you want to play
something else or you want to perhaps
capture the point if you capture the
pawn you allow this night to be eight
move to harass your Bishop and after the
bishop moves here comes Knight to c6
check and the thing is if you capture
with the Bishop then this will be a draw
but if you don't capture if you click
into b5 then white will again be winning
but it's not all that easy to decide to
go into a variation like this for
example Knight capture skin captures
King to c7 stopping king b6 but now
White has before and the two passed
pawns with the beautiful bishop on f3
are much stronger than the lonely rock
on a7 whatever black plays white will
simply continue pushing the pawns and
after this a7 is coming and there is
nothing you can do here and the the king
the the King and Bishop will prevent the
three points to be traded for for the 1
G to pawn and the white will be winning
here but although this is a winning move
official finds a much nicer way he plays
rook to d5 with Chuck we have king to d7
and here Fischer simply played King to
b5 and it was in this position that
marked a man of one of the strongest
Ovid grandmasters of that time resigned
the game why did he resign well whatever
you do here the the same idea 98 we've
shown in the previous variation doesn't
work here because you simply get rocked
the c5 check after up to c5 check you
can either go King b8 and get rook c8
checkmate or you can decide to move to
remove the King for example King d7 and
then like we've mentioned if you get
your King over to b6 it's game over
because the rook is now trapped you
would have to give up the rook and then
after it captures you threaten the Queen
there's nothing you can do here you
would have to give up the night and then
now white is up a whole rook of course
completely winning here
so yeah after king to see seven official
play king b5 and it was in this position
that market Amman of resigned so yeah
that's the game from round 19 of the
1970 palma de mallorca intra zonal
tournament I do hope you enjoyed it and
that you're enjoying the coverage of the
series so far as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
most likely with around 20 of the 9070
palma de mallorca inter-zonal tournament
thank you all and I'll see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your Saturday
evening